[Musique]
il y a quand même un truc
très spécial en fait quand on est ici
c'est que je vois pas du tout
je vois absolument aucun regard et je
vous assure c'est très bizarre de parler
à des gens sans pouvoir son pouvoir les
voir la lumière c'est bien mais ça fait
ça fait un peu comme un mur en fait vous
êtes d'à côté je suis de l'autre je sais
que c'est le principe c'est le principe
des conférences mais c'est très bizarre
de parler à des gens sans pouvoir les
voir donc j'ai demandé ce qu'on reste
éclairé un peu plus longtemps
pour que je puisse aussi vous vous
regardez parce que j'ai l'impression que
quand je vous vois ben vous me voyez
mieux et quand je vous vois ben j'ai
l'impression que vous m'entendez mieux
et puis moi quand je vous vois ben je
vous ressens mieux je vous entends mieux
en fait hein
je vais vous parler de communication
la communication c'est un truc assez
magnifique c'est comme ça que nous les
humains
on partage des idées des émotions des
méthodes
quand on rit quand on chante quand on
danse quand on se raconte des histoires
on communique
on communique et c'est comme ça que tous
les humains et ben on se fabrique une
culture commune
communication ça vient de commun
c'est faire comme
c'est d'autant plus important de faire
commun en ce moment qu'on est confronté
à un défi énorme
notre mode de vie notre façon de
consommer de produire est en train de
détruire le vivant et nous avec on est
en train de rendre la planète que nous
habitons inhabitable
comment on fait comme un face à cet
énorme problème commun qui nous tombe
dessus et auquel on doit s'habituer
d'urgence
comment on fait économie autrement
comment on fait société autrement
comment on sort de nos modes de pensée
consumériste
comment s'adapte en tant qu'espèce à un
truc pareil
en fait il y a une majorité d'entre nous
qui a une idée hyper clair sur la
question
pour 68% des Français
l'effondrement de notre civilisation est
imminente
71% des Italiens en gros on l'a notre
vision commune on a une un imaginaire
collectif dominant et c'est le mur qu'on
va se prendre si on fait rien
si c'est la seule chose qu'on voit
alors à côté de cette grosse majorité de
pessimistes
on a une petite minorité alors hyper
optimiste des gens qui ont plein d'idées
sur le progrès humain sur l'avenir de
l'humanité sur les bienfaits de la
technologie
c'est les milliardaires
ah là là les milliardaires ils ont plein
d'idées vous voyez derrière moi c'est
[Musique]
c'est la fusée de Jeff Bezos
c'est une fusée phallus ça a fallu ça
c'est une fusée phallus pour aller en
semence et l'univers
concrètement en fait d'un Evol c'était
quatre types qui allaient admirer la
planète pendant que nous on est en train
de griller dessus donc on tiendra pas
tous de toute façon
alors il y a pas que il y a pas que Jeff
Bezos qui a des idées il y en a un autre
qui a plein d'idées c'est lui
Elon Musk alors Elon Musk c'est génial
parce que lui il ne paye pas sa
communication paye pas pour faire de la
pub il raconte ses idéaux médias et les
médias nous racontent ces idées ça fait
que vous pouvez considérer que l'article
que vous avez derrière moi là c'est une
publicité ça veut dire que tous les mots
comptent donc qu'est-ce qu'on apprend
déjà on apprend que c'est un friendly
robot
le designer s'est ramassé complètement
et le frein des robots en question il
effectue des tâches sans intérêt
c'est vrai regardez
la formation importante bien sûr c'est
la dernière
c'est qui monte
c'est à dire qu'en réalité ce robot
il vous tape pas si vous le tapez
moi c'est la première fois
que j'entends parler d'un produit dont
l'argument de vente et qu'il a les
pannes taper si je le tapais
les gens doivent taper leur robot vous
savez
la formation c'est bien entendu que
c'est une entrée de gamme
il faut bien comprendre que il y a
d'autres robots programmés pour nous
mettre des branler qui va pas tarder
alors en réalité
les milliardaires ils sont surtout
optimistes pour eux
pour nous ils sont super pessimistes
je crois pas qu'ils pensent qu'on va y
arriver
eux ce qui nous propose comme vision de
l'humanité c'est une humanité coupée du
reste de l'humanité coupé de son
humanité
voilà
bonnement intérêt à pas attendre de
devenir tous milliardaires pour des
idées et qu'on s'autorise le droit
d'imaginer un avenir possible pour nous
pour nos enfants
un avenir où ils pourront être heureux
et libre
je sais pas si on s'accorde ce droit là
c'est pas sûr qu'on se l'accorde
collectivement je veux dire ce qu'on
produit Ensemble est-ce qu'on s'accorde
ce droit là est-ce qu'on se projette
dans les trucs comme ça pas vraiment en
fait
faut dire que le mot transition nous
aide pas beaucoup
la transition transition ok mais
transition vers où
on sait pas trop on sait qu'il va
falloir consommer moins on sait qu'il va
falloir produire moins on sait qu'il va
falloir détruire moi
ça nous fait pas un autre monde ça
c'est le même
mais le même
moins destructeur
[Musique]
ça reste pas possible on a du mal à se
dire qu'il faut un changement pluradical
que ça c'est pas celui-là en un peu
moins bien qui nous faut là en 50 ans on
vient de détruire 70% de la vie sauvage
la transition elle est peut-être
plus culturel en fait
peut-être que la transition c'est
d'abord une transition vers un autre
imaginaire vers un autre système de
représentation d'autres images
parce que on va avoir quand même
beaucoup de mal à inventer un autre
avenir s'il y a des seuls imaginaire
qu'on a notre disposition c'est celui du
monde qu'on veut remplacer
si on veut inventer un autre monde faut
inventer d'autres images
le spot que je voudrais vous montrer
c'est celui-là
pardon pour le son
en fait
c'est pas parce que je l'aime bien je
l'aime bien je l'ai mis par commodité
pour me faire comprendre en fait dans ce
film vous avez un jeune type qui claque
des doigts il a une super bagnole il
claque des doigts il a une super meuf il
claque des doigts il a une chance de
dingue il claque des doigts il a un
lingot d'or et il claque des doigts il a
un parfum
en fait ce que nous dit ce film ce spot
c'est que pour 40 euros tu as un million
ça peut paraître un raccourci bien sûr
si une image mais c'est le deal de la
société consumériste en fait
la question qu'on doit se poser c'est OK
parce que là vous voyez ce spot il vous
choque pas comme vous le voyez la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on va être bien pouvoir
mettre en terme de désir pour rivaliser
avec pour 40 euros tu as un million
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir inventer
en termes de représentation de l'amour
du bonheur de la réussite
pour qu'on se dise 40 euros pour un
million c'est beaucoup trop cher
en réalité
il va falloir qu'on sorte un peu de
notre zone de confort et qu'on aille
chercher d'autres choses au fond de nous
que ce qu'on subit en permanence
[Musique]
il y a le un grand soldat américain qui
s'appelle discotheron qui chantait que
la révolution serait pas télévisée
et en fait il a raison la Révolution a
déjà commencé en fait elle a commencé
sur tous les continents tous les
territoires tous les pays mais on est
tellement absorbé par le spectacle de
l'effondrement de cette société en fin
de cycle
qu'on voit pas qu'il y a un autre monde
qui est en train de naître et l'histoire
elle est assez incroyable parce que dans
le même temps où l'homme produisait ce
modèle économique extractif
celui qu'on connaît le modèle
capitaliste consumériste il inventait
dans le même temps une autre économie
ça fait plus de 50 ans que l'homme a
inventé une autre façon
de faire économie de coopérer avec le
vivant de coopérer avec ces semblables
c'est une économie régénérative nous
entendre parler c'est à dire une
économie qui régénère les écosystèmes
vivants et sociaux dont elle dépend au
lieu de les détruire
cette économie vous la connaissez c'est
c'est la permaculture l'Open Source
l'économie circulaire l'économie sociale
et solidaire l'agroécologie ce sont
toutes ces dizaines de pratiques mais
qui forment en fait une seule espèce
économique et c'est quand toutes ces
pratiques sont reliées entre elles sur
un territoire et qu'elle
œuvre ensemble qu'elles font écosystème
c'est là qu'elle produisent le plus de
de performance et de prospérité pour les
habitants
c'est Isabelle Delannoy la scientifique
qui a écrit le film Home de Yann Artus
Bertrand qui a fait cette découverte en
fait
elle a rencontré tous les plus grands
spécialistes de la planète ils ont tous
été formels si on n'a pas enclenché un
autre modèle économique dans la décennie
2020 on va pas y arriver
donc c'est quand même une sacrée bonne
nouvelle le modèle économique capable de
remplacer celui qui nous conduit dans le
mur il existe
mais maintenant il faut l'aider à
réussir
c'est ce modèle c'est ce que vous voyez
d'ailleurs on le voit de plus en plus
au niveau local vous le voyez dans votre
quartier dans votre ville dans votre
village c'est toutes ces nouvelles
propositions ces nouveaux produits ces
nouveaux services que vous voyez des
tiers-lieux des coopératives des
starters des nouvelles boutiques c'est
toutes ces nouvelles marques qui
apparaissent dans votre environnement et
qui sont des marques configurées un peu
autrement que des marques que l'on
connaissait
et donc
la question c'est comment on va les
aider à réussir comment on va les aider
à être préféré en fait c'est Marc là le
problème qu'elles ont c'est que aucune a
les moyens d'aller à la télévision
aucune peut se payer une campagne
massive à la télévision la seule
possibilité pour elle c'est de coopérer
avec les autres marques de façon à ce
que ensemble elle parviennent à produire
suffisamment de de bruits communs pour
pouvoir exister dans cet environnement
extrêmement
bruyant dans lequel on est
et pour y arriver ben elles ont un atout
que possède aucune multinationale elles
ont un truc génial c'est que elle elles
ont un écosystème avec lequel coopérer
c'est à dire des communautés de valeurs
qu'elle partage avec d'autres marques
qui leur permettent d'agir ensemble et
qui leur permet de
d'envisager une coopération alors le
problème qu'on a en communication
c'est que
le modèle que j'ai appris dans les
grandes agences de pub
celui qu'on apprend dans toutes les
écoles de commerce et de communication
en fait cette façon de penser de la
publicité quand on veut coopérer assez
rien elle sert à rien pour la simple et
bonne raison que elle l'ensemble de
cette pensée là est conçu uniquement
autour du lait de compétition
alors c'est pour une raison très simple
c'est que c'est un modèle qui a été
pensé au milieu du siècle dernier dans
un contexte de croissance d'après-guerre
les fameuses trentes glorieuses il
fallait à cette époque-là il fallait
qu'on peut comprendre que cette
époque-là il y a eu l'utilité d'avoir
une marque qui n'est qu'un objet de
compétition dont l'objectif est de
dominer ses concurrents pour conquérir
le plus de parts de marché possible
ok mais mais
en fait on va pas pouvoir créer de
coopération avec un outil conçu pour la
compétition on peut pas visser avec un
marteau
comment sur le ça je vais vous dire
c'est que en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'une marque est une
fiction une marque c'est un signe auquel
on va attribuer un certain nombre de
qualité de caractéristiques
une marque vue comme un objet de
compétition bah c'est aussi une fiction
une marque c'est un outil
on peut décider de croire à notre
histoire
on peut décider qu'une marque c'est un
outil de coopération donc on va créer
une nouvelle marque
qui va appartenir à toutes les parties
prenantes et dont le rôle est d'être
service des autres marques
lorsqu'on pense la communication comme
ça lorsqu'on se
lorsqu'on se projette dans cette
possibilité d'agir en commun avec
d'autres on ouvre d'autres possibilités
et on ouvre d'autres possibilités en
termes de puissance de capacité à
exister dans l'espace public
dans dans ce monde là celui que vous
voyez je vous montrais la reventation de
la puissance telle qu'elle existe pardon
je sais pas si on la voit c'est celle-ci
ça c'est une représentation de la
puissance et au fond c'est la
verticalité du modèle économique c'est
la puissance telle qu'on le voit dans le
monde économique
c'est à dire c'est la
publicité télé c'est un truc qui vous
tombe dessus c'est l'arrosage intensif
c'était un industriel américain au
siècle dernier qui disait je sais que la
moitié de mon budget de communication ne
sert à rien le problème c'est que j'ai
pas de quelle moitié il s'agit
et ben c'est ça la recherche intensif
maintenant je vais vous montrer une
autre présentation de la puissance et
cette autre représentation de la
puissance c'est celle de la vague
la vague aussi la puissance
et une vague c'est une toute autre
puissance qu'une tour c'est à dire qu'il
y a aucune tour qui peut résister à une
vague on les a vu les tours pendant le
covid elles étaient assez fragile quand
elles étaient toutes vies de la les
millions de de bureaux désertés
une vague c'est beaucoup plus puissant
qu'une tour
c'est quoi une vague
une vague c'est une goutte d'eau plus
une goutte d'eau plus une goutte d'eau
plus une goutte d'eau
quand vous vous représentez le sentiment
d'être dépassé par rapport à tout ça ou
un puissant par rapport à tout ce
changement à accomplir
et vous vous sentez une goutte d'eau
demandez-vous quel goutte d'eau vous
êtes
est-ce que vous êtes une goutte d'eau
sur un papier buvard est-ce que vous
êtes un goutte d'eau sur un bout de
bureau ou est-ce que vous êtes une
goutte d'eau parmi d'autres gouttes
d'eau
parce que si vous êtes une goutte d'eau
parmi d'autres gouttes d'eau alors vous
êtes une goutte d'eau
alors vous êtes une vague
alors on a une vague
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]